[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau cette ut le journal
voici les titres de l'actualité
najat vallaud belkacem était en
déplacement dans les yvelines cet après
midi la ministre de l'éducation a visité
le chantier de réhabilitation de la
maison léon blum de jouy en josas et le
lycée franco allemand de buc sur le même
thème ce matin était organisée au lycée
hôtelier de liancourt en forum
départemental à l'occasion de la semaine
sur la persévérance scolaire à temps de
rencontre pour prévenir les signes de
décrochage a marché solidaire était
organisée samedi dernier dans le cadre
du jumelage entre la ville de qom et au
bénin et guyancourt
la recette doit servir au financement de
projets de développement au bénéfice de
com et sans surprise jean frédéric
poisson a été réélu au poste de
président du parti chrétien démocrate
outre sa réélection le député de la 10e
circonscription des yvelines en a
profité pour rappeler son soutien
françois fillon à l'élection
présidentielle tout en dénonçant
l'accord avec l'ue dei et le peu de
considération de françois fillon à
l'égard du pcd politique toujours là
ministre de l'éducation en à jade
vallaud belkacem était en déplacement
dans les yvelines cet après midi elle a
visité le chantier de réhabilitation de
la maison léon blum de lui en jeu de
jouy en josas
elle a fait aussi un détour au lycée
franco allemand de buc pour assister au
travail de préparation entre des
collégiens français et allemand notre
journaliste nicolas kirillovitch étaient
sur place
1945 1950 léon blum hommes politiques
emblématiques de l'histoire socialiste a
passé les dernières années de sa vie
dans cette maison une maison devenue
avec le temps lieu de visite est en
travaux depuis la fin 2016 700000 euros
investis pour améliorer notamment
l'accueil du public et entretenir le
devoir de mémoire
je vois bien en quoi c'est d'abord un
atout pour nos élèves donc l'aspect
pédagogique la dimension scientifique
été rappelé avec ce comité scientifique
est essentiel et je crois que ça peut
être un atout dans ce travail de mémoire
que nous devons mener durant sa visite
la ministre s'est également rendu sur la
tombe de celui qui fut en 1936 chef de
gouvernement du front populaire époque
où hitler commencent à imposer sa vision
à l'europe et où l'espagne débute sa
guerre civile
il y à cette référence qu'on peut faire
à tout moment dans la vie de léon blum à
des situations réellement actuelle ça
peut être la menace de tels telle ou
telle extrémisme ça peut être la vision
d'une d'une ouverture sur le plan social
ça peut être la relation avec les pays
étrangers comme les états unis la
réouverture de la maison léon blum est
prévue pour septembre prochain les
travaux devraient permettre d'accueillir
jusqu'à 5000 visiteurs par an près de
cent mille jeunes sortent chaque année
du système scolaire sans diplôme
ils sont tristement appelés les
décrocheurs pour les aider l'académie de
versailles organise une semaine de la
persévérance scolaire
un temps de rencontre pour prévenir les
signes de décrochage
un reportage de mélanie poker
on s'initie à la relaxation au collège
anatole-france des clayes-sous-bois 10 à
15 minutes d'ateliers pour une classe de
5e le bien-être à l'école pour lutter
contre le décrochage
on essaye de les initier à la relaxation
et ensuite on est on renforce les
compétences psychosociales notamment les
compétences savoir gérer son stress et
émotion avoir des relations apaisées
gérer ces conflits
petit à petit on voit leur ça que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut faire
régulièrement mais du coup c'est vrai
que mais il a plu pluies vont apprendre
à prendre de la distance à respirer
calmement et plus effectivement levés ya
de moins en moins de conflits c'est axa
aide
leur expérience est l'une de celles
mises en valeur par l'académie de
versailles
chaque année environ 15 mille jeunes
arrêtent l'école
c'est un chiffre qui bouge à peu près
tous les deux jours pour la raison
simple que c'est extrêmement difficile à
compter les décrocheurs
donc on est sûr effectivement un ordre
de grandeur
plus qu'un chiffre n'est l'ordre de
grandeur est le bon puisque la vraie
donnée c'est le nombre de jeunes qui
quittent le système scolaire sans
qualification
ceux là on les connaît et effectivement
on peut les qualifier de décrocheurs
reprise d'études activités manuelles ou
encore travail sur l'estimé de soi 500
décrocheurs sont opérés dans les
yvelines chaque année
mercredi 8 mars le pôle jeunesse de
montigny le bretonneux en partenariat
avec l'association yvelines information
jeunesse organisé un forum initiatives
jeunes
un événement qui devait permettre aux 15
25 ans de mieux identifier les
dispositifs de soutien et de financement
possibles pour concrétiser leur projet
sur la ville de montigny à des
dispositifs
d'accompagnement et de financement de
projets qui s'appelle la bourse aux
projets la bourse bafa également 2
dz pour trouver un stage en europe par
le biais du service événementiel
mais il ya aussi différents partenaires
qui sont présents aujourd'hui pour aider
les jeunes dans leurs projets de
mobilité européenne internationale ou
aussi des projets de volontariat
bénévolat service civique aussi en fait
c'est plein de pistes pour réaliser
leurs projets au quotidien
les étudiants en droit de l'association
juris tribune ont redonné vie au procès
de la ferme erin une reconstitution
réalisée au tribunal de versailles
vendredi dernier une plongée dans les
années 70 avec nicolas d'andry ennemi
public numéro un homme le plus recherché
en france dans les années 70 jacques
mary n'a été l'auteur de plusieurs
braquages
il reprend vit aujourd'hui sous les
traits de félix boutillon étudiant en
droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin
[Musique]
j'en ai terminé
il est charismatique il est bon il est
complètement il est violent ils se sont
montrés violents et peut se montrer
complètement complètement hors de lui
comme s'il est énervé mais c'est un
gentleman pour sa reconstitution annuel
l'association juriste tribune a choisi
le procès de jacques mesrine
les témoins se succèdent à la barre face
à eux deux doctorants dans lé rôle de
procureurs et avocats de la défense
la vice doyenne de la faculté de droit
de l'université versailles saint quentin
mari et ma boursiers dans la peau de la
présidente de cour d'assises c'est de
protéger la société contre ce genre
d'individu que vous devez le monde l
adhésion
à la question le sujet est il coupable
même verdict qu'en 1977 le shaq mérine
de 2017 est condamné à 20 ans de
réclusion assortie d'une mesure de
sûreté de 10 ans et d'une amende de 150
mille francs
ces procès revisitée sont organisés
depuis dix ans et attire toujours autant
d'étudiants leurs intérêts mettre en
pratique le droit mettre en pratique sa
culture juridique d'une autre manière
découvrir le droit le droit bas au
travers de professions juridiques
finalement qu'on aura que pour beaucoup
avec un peu de chance on réalisera plus
tard et voilà c'est vraiment pour moi le
réel intérêt et même redécouvrir des
affaires qui finalement ont marqué
l'histoire
c'est toujours intéressant de voir des
cas concret parce que on a beaucoup de
théories et ça permet de voir plus
concrètement à quoi ça correspond à
procès les procédures et tout savoir
comment ça se passe réellement puisque
si on veut être avocat ou magistrat sans
assister à des procès ça n'a pas
d'intérêt
rendez vous l'année prochaine pour un
nouveau procès une nouvelle affaire mais
celle au jet est à l'honneur au centre
commercial ce week end vélizy
villacoublay
le sculpteur a proposé en personne des
visites de sa collection rhinocéros
écouter l'artiste au micro de nicolas
d'andré vous allez voir tout un tout une
production aussi bien des toutes petites
pièces des bijoux de l'art de la table
des stylos des grosses pièces dans la
sculpture
il ya des thèmes qui sont totalement
récurrent qui sont la femme ou toute la
sculpture animalière
je crois que c'est important aujourd'hui
de se servir des techniques les plus
contemporaines et les plus modernes et
aujourd'hui on a des noms là pour
m'aider coupage travaille avec des
découpages de lasers et là on travaille
avec des scanners de volume et après on
a des logiciels pour lequel on peut
prévoir la découpe et après on se dit
qu'on découpe les pièces on reconstitue
la pièce dans le cadre du jumelage entre
la ville de com et au bénin et guy
rancourt un marché solidaire était
organisée samedi dernier tous les objets
vendus serviront au financement de
projets de développement au bénéfice de
comè tout le comité de jumelage de
guyancourt s'est retroussé les manches
chacun a fabriqué des petits objets pour
les revendre ce jour là sur ce marché
solidaire bijoux vêtements produits
culinaires il y en avait pour tous les
goûts
alors j'ai acheté une petite poule pour
mettre dans mon jardin pour ma vraie
poule parce que j'ai une vraie poule ça
c'est de la confiture parce que je vais
gourmands les recettes des ventes
permettront aux comités de financer des
projets pour le développement de com et
au bénin ville jumelle de guyancourt
comme elle se situe à 60 km de cotonou
la capitale le micro projet pour lequel
nous travaillons actuellement
c'est un projet de plantation de 300
arbres dans certaines rues de com et les
arbres seront plantés en juin prochain
par des enfants de comé afin de les
sensibiliser aux questions
environnementales
en 2008 le jumelage avait permis de
fournir une nouvelle pirogue pour que
les jeunes de com et puissent se rendre
à l'école au-delà de ces aides
le comité poursuit une autre ambition
découvrir connaître à avoir des échanges
avec des habitants d'autres pays donc
quand c'est en europe c'est assez près
de nous mais on a quand même des
cultures un peu différente avec un pays
qui se trouvent en afrique on a comment
dire d'autant plus d'inconnues séparer
de six mille six cents kilomètres les
deux villes profitent de ce type
d'événement pour créer un pont entre
deux cultures
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivis prochaine édition
demain à 18 heures bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]